no question
the quickest way to happiness is
accountability when people start looking
for somebody else
to be at fault whether it's the
government
or their aunt or some or their [ __ ]
boss they always lose
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
the throwback stuff is so popular
because some of the stuff you're saying
is crazy
how long it was it's kind of a wet one
this would be a great podcast
what the [ __ ] is the most underrated
company on the internet today
let's [ __ ] go i want you to get what
amazon stock price was on april 6 2011.
so everybody's
trying to figure out which company is
gonna win this victim you can start it
with like hey if you were listening to
gary and bought a thousand shooters at
amazon
on this day for this price it'd be worth
this much now
that'd be an amazing video two companies
really stick in my craw
amazon and netflix they were just good
entrepreneurs everybody's
trying to figure out which company is
gonna win this big tech
battle i've been thinking it's gonna be
amazon i actually think
amazon yeah is the most underrated
company on the internet today this
company has always shown the ability to
innovate they understood commerce
they went out and bought zappos for
culture you know i like that because
that's thank you economy
every day that goes by i'm continue to
be impressed by how amazon
executes delivers and creates innovation
that is bringing money to its bottom
line and so for you sitting down
watching
i gotta be honest you know i know jim
kramer so a lot of people think i get
crazy
i think amazon may win this whole thing
[Music]
that's [ __ ] amazing
[Music]
fireside chat with jessica alba this is
just the podcast
uh what up podcast this was a talk i did
about 18 months ago with jessica alba
it was really great for the whole
company and just a lot of insights that
i think are timeless which is why i
wanted everybody to
read it and read it listen to it i hope
you enjoy it thank you so much for
watching jesus christ listening to the
podcast i don't know why i want you guys
to read and watch my podcast
i'm very passionate that audio and
listening is the future
uh i'm actually recording this while i'm
about to give this talk in dc
and i've been on vacation for about a
week and literally i just could see the
rust coming out in this little pre-read
so
anyway hit me up on twitter and say hey
rusty b
and uh and enjoy this podcast
what i just did is what nobody ever does
and it's so
human and it's so much bet what yeah
it's 100 that's exactly right you know
how else i feel about that steroids i
think people should do steroids
like i actually like kind of logically
now let me preface this all on the
record
i'm not educated at all
[Laughter]
is this for the podcast i believe it's a
microclip
yeah it doesn't matter either way hey
guys what you're about to watch and or
listen to depending on how you roll
is uh two minutes and change on my
thoughts
about a lot of my friends and
acquaintances in the business world
talking about you know
different drugs different you know
aspects of the mind
and it was just a fun little clip
forget about politics i just don't want
to talk about it but i want to talk
about one thing that i just want
everybody to know about america
if you're willing to try to cross the
border illegally into our country
knowing that you are going to be
potentially and now highly likely
separated from your four to
eight-year-old for six months
potentially
imagine what the [ __ ] you're running
from we're just so lucky
i don't know what to say first of all
we're just like i couldn't imagine if
the first 25 years of my life were spent
in soviet russia
[Music]
my grandfathers both went to jail for
being like me
[Music]
i get to be put on a pedestal
look at me look at me my class photo
secondhand season oh dead weinstock
jason cass and i'm michael wong
wakeel shaw [ __ ] i remember a lot
michael socia i'm [ __ ] killing it
wait this is all off in memory oh yeah i
just did that off memory
and i and i moved in seventh grade so i
haven't seen these people since 87 or
something
when did they officially acknowledge
that that was a poop emoji
because wasn't it like an ice cream cone
for a while like weren't they trying to
say that
or that was just hearsay okay what made
you think of that
i spelled poop and it shows it i do my
emojis now by spelling them out
me too it's faster it's way faster than
[ __ ] trying to find it
when i type on instagram i type the name
of the emoji
and then i pick the the emoji shows up
in the bottom there i'm pissed when i
type in it's not coming up the emoji
yeah what the hell is it
there's a hack you can live on six
have 18 hours 18 goddamn hours
i want to know what you're doing with
your 18 hours
[Music]
live stream from uh
teamgaryvee and send a [ __ ]
ins first in line right now to
t that team garyvee is live streaming
gary live from dc
just for you guys first in line go to
this like
a do you want to film a video real quick
uh sure
first in line what's up trying to get
some light here first in line i'm going
on stage in dc right now team garyvee is
streaming it live click there make sure
you follow the teamgaryvee
instagram account tons of awesome [ __ ]
there hope you enjoy this keynote go
what am i on all right andy go get a
good spot
[Applause]
one thing i'm positive about is how roi
negative complaining is and how much
i'm trying to suffocate the practice of
it
it has been remarkably important to me
in understanding that everything that
i'm not happy about
has is on me it's it's a remarkably
interesting brain twist the amount of
energy spent on things that you can't
control
versus being accountable to what you can
control has been a huge
separator for me in the last four or
five years as i've dug deep and so
if i was able to have a couple things
happen out of this talk
this morning one is
just self-awareness just like do you
actually know who you are so many people
wishing there's something
instead of understanding what they are
number two is accountability
no question the quickest way to
happiness
is accountability when people start
looking for somebody else
to be at fault whether it's the
government
or their aunt or some or their [ __ ]
boss
they always lose i really want to make
sure that people leave here knowing
who they are do you understand yourself
do you
actually have a situation where you
judge yourself within yourself
or do you allow other people's opinions
to dictate your life there is nothing
nothing more difficult than navigating
your life
based on somebody else's opinion
[Music]
job thank you man thank you for this
yeah
[Music]
i've always felt comfortable with it
when i started vlogging
and had drock film me there was already
vlogging
but like casey and others they were
doing it themselves
so me having a different human do it was
three years ago was a little intense
you're welcome
you're welcome
you got it one life do something
i think people take things for granted
do you know it's you're more likely to
win the lottery ten times than be alive
i love that [ __ ] 400 trillion to one
according to current scientists 400
trillion to one
everybody in this room is likely to get
by lightning seven times
more likely than being alive that's
great steve that's crazy
[Music]
you better out running with the bulls
and running with that [ __ ]
yeah you better out running with the
bulls and running with that [ __ ]
you better off running with the bulls
and running with that [ __ ] knock it
out the park while i'm sitting
and it's definitely way [ __ ] more
competitive now than it was
18 months ago uh maybe even like six
months ago yeah it makes sense what
uh so i mean it's not from like the
masses that you were talking to today
what's what's the next [ __ ] it's it's on
facebook
no it's it's that it's it's contextual
creative though yeah
i think where we're getting better is
like i'll like
i told them and it really clicked
recently for us because i've been on it
but we haven't been executing on it
i was like if we're gonna make content
like literally in this
in this uh green room an hour ago two
hours ago i said to them
no let me just make an ad and be like
hey usc grads
like did it and then you run it against
usc grads yeah like it's just contextual
yeah yeah yeah it's less you know like
the insta
facebook and instagram are content
platforms not advertising
platforms when you run ads what you
realize is you're at the no matter how
math no matter how top nerd you are
you're at the mercy of the creative
yeah yeah and and when the creative
kills
the cost drops the engagement the
engagement goes through the roof you get
your your you know your earned cpms go
through the roof
which drops down your actual cost yeah
yeah and so like relevant score
all that stuff just the cost because if
you're getting shares in word of mouth
and you're getting an extra million
impressions that you didn't pay for
because of actual social media
people forgot about that part well then
the creative
is the answer yeah
it's a really good song to sew up
[Music]
what time is our flight 10 so i want to
leave at 8 40.
like 8 50 at the latest or
talk some cash [ __ ] on these folks man
let them know who the originators is in
this [ __ ]
because i got a lot of kids doing it in
the rap game
matter of fact i don't claim
me that i was next you talking big in
your pot trying to catch me in my new
drop
jfk with two shots i know that ain't how
you uh i'm so
up right now
[Music]
they feel so good free is best when you
can do your thing
i couldn't be more passionate about you
going to
downtown whatever wherever the [ __ ] you
are now
and like doing it for somebody like
literally like hey pizza joe are you
doing your front of your store just get
it on ink
the biggest issue for kids a lot of time
is proof of concept
free is an awfully tough thing to pass
on one thing with free
do something for free that lets you do
what the [ __ ] you want to do
free for the sake of free but the owner
of the [ __ ] store
doesn't let you do [ __ ] isn't good for
you you need a
you need like louis vuitton you need
like virgil to be like that's the
freshest [ __ ] i've ever seen on social
media who did that
you see where i'm going we just did
something free from
it's gonna change our company now vayner
100 [ __ ] 50 million in revenue free
changed my business
now